how far is too far when it comes to TV
that potentially grosse line is always
changing today you can find just about
everybody part and swear word on the
small screen at any given time of the
day but there was a time when TV was a
bit more conservative whether or not
they'll be shocking today here are a few
TV moments that took things too far
graphic content the CBS sitcom 2 Broke
Girls follows the exploits of to New
York waitresses as they attempt to start
their own cupcake business but many
viewers find the pair far from sweet
complaints sent to the FCC about the
show's content included one woman urging
the authorities to review an episode
that depicts and naked doll being
manipulated into quote-unquote graphic
sexual acts of course how graphic a
Barbie can be without actual genitals is
a different question entirely
booby-trapped
when married with children premiered in
1987 owl peg and the rest of the Bundy's
went the picture-perfect family America
was so used to seeing al constantly
called peg a horrible housewife mother
and cook while peg was there to let her
husband know just how inadequate he was
as the man of the house but it was an
episode that took place in a bra shop
that was the breaking point for one
michigan woman terri Rakolta the episode
compelled her to start a letter-writing
campaign encouraging a boycott of the
show i sent my children out of the room
after five minutes of this trash but I'm
sorry to watch and see what kind of
low-class advertisers will support this
type of program Rakolta x' campaign
became legitimate news a few advertisers
pulled their ads and at least one
episode wasn't aired but ultimately the
publicity that Rakolta generated for the
show is credited for helping it find its
audience and stay on the air for 11
seasons so you have Terry Rakolta to
thank for classy jokes
like this I had steak tonight what are
you having if I was the mailman I'd be
having your wife raining on your parade
never afraid to push the boundaries of
good taste for a laugh one episode of
Seinfeld crossed the line between humor
and bigotry
according to Bronx borough president
Fernando Ferrer he was one of numerous
viewers offended by a plotline that saw
the main characters caught up in a
traffic jam
caused by the Puerto Rican Day Parade
and desecrating a Puerto Rican flag
causing angry bystanders to toss their
car down a stairwell like this every day
apart both the comment and a flag
burning provoked outrage with the
National Puerto Rican the coalition
calling it an unquestionable insult to
the country and demanding an apology
from NBC the network quickly complied
Family Guy's second ban
once accused of anti-semitism the Family
Guy episode when you wish upon a
Weinstein was temporarily banned on Fox
but eventually add four years after was
originally produced and after the show
had already gone to depths that were
arguably far worse however the network
refused to relent when it came to the
season 8 finale partial terms of
endearment the so called abortion
episode was made but rejected with both
Fox and Adult Swim exercising their
right not to air it instead it was
released as a standalone DVD and on BBC
three in the UK creator Seth MacFarlane
saw it as a cop-out aimed at placating
conservative viewers saying times really
have changed the network is making a
decision that is unfortunately probably
based on people's current ability to
handle and dissect controversial
narratives it wasn't the first or last
time Fox would deal with censorship
issues everything's relative the classic
sci-fi series the x-files
also had an episode banned for
inappropriate content
was the first-ever x-files episode to
begin with a viewer discretion warning
and remained the only one to carry a TV
ma rating which it probably deserved the
plot follows Mulder and Scully as they
investigate a secluded farmhouse after
an abandoned baby is found nearby what
they discover are three brothers the
younger two fathered by the eldest which
makes for a very complicated and gross
family tree when you know II hope boy
will do anything for his mother Fox
removed the episode from syndication and
only repeated at once as part of a 1999
Halloween special advertising it as an
episode so controversial it's been
banned from television for three years
right on no homeless Club while the
Simpsons usually takes a more subtle
approach to lampooning its targets then
shows like Family Guy or South Park when
Springfield's first family poked fun at
Brazil they almost wound up causing a
diplomatic incident the episode blame it
on Lisa saw the Simpsons head to Brazil
and face all manners of trouble upon
arrival Homer is kidnapped by a cabbie
he and Bart are mugged by children and
there are rampant monkey attacks the
drunkenness be ambiguous sexuality the
country's President Fernando Henrique
Cardoso thought it brought a distortion
of Brazilian reality to the screen the
Rio Tourism Board agreed claiming that
the 18 million that had recently spent
on promoting the city in the States who
has now wasted being while a little over
a decade later the 2016 Olympics
actually verified a few of the Simpson's
claims did it for Dexter when a show
portrays a serial killer
as a charismatic champion of justice
with a pretty sweet Miami Life it's
bound to attract a few copycats in
January 2014 two
one year old Macau was found guilty of
murdering his mother after she been
slashed more than 50 times house search
history featured gems like Dexter's kill
knife and what does a sociopath need to
do to blend in seamlessly with society
but clearly not how to clear browser
history dummy the event reignited the
debate over whether the show should be
taken off the air since it wasn't even
the first murder to be blamed on
Showtime's crime drama in 2008 aspiring
Canadian filmmaker Mark Twitchell who
had been going under the name Dexter
Morgan on Facebook lured two men to his
home under the pretense of making a
horror film about a sword wielding mass
murderer
Twitchell killed one of the men and the
other managed to escape and we can't
forget Jessica Lopez who strangled a
woman and attempted to chop her up like
the show's protagonist starring Hitler
some of Britain's greatest exports have
been created at the UK's famous Pinewood
Studios but not everything that comes
out of the world-renowned studio is
guaranteed to be a success hi honey
oh honey I'm home hile honey I'm home
was supposed to follow a reimagined
version of Adolf Hitler and his partner
Ava Braun as they deal with living next
door to a Jewish couple the show a 1990
spoof of terrible sitcoms failed right
out of the gate I'm a very very bad
Hitler the now-defunct galaxy channel
was forced to pull the plug after the
pilot episode because of accusations of
anti-semitism
brighto Bragg Atkinson has always
insisted his intentions were
misunderstood saying sometimes you can
destroy beliefs by laughing at them this
isn't about denying what happened it's
about being human in the face of
inhumanity about a decade later comedy
fans were finally ready to embrace the
absurdity of a comedic Hitler ah hooray
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to